[Musique]
françois je ne trouve pas que le jardin
est un peu trop calme aujourd'hui ah oui
ça c'est vrai que raison je lis il y
manque vraiment un petit peu d'animation
tu sais pour en mettre tu devrais te
déguiser en clown pique nique aux
enclos du pique nique ou non je veux
bien mobilisés mais pas au bout d'une
pique nique alors on est alors femmes ce
que détective m'aider mais julie band +
1 me la seule mineure
punie je vais me déguise litres au
docteur dar bichi
tu crois que casimir et monsieur 19e
reconnaîtront nous verrons bien je vais
coller ma barbichette tu allais les
prévenir d'accord elle françois
dépêche-toi
casimir
tu sais la nouvelle non le docteur
barbiche ou via nous rendre visite
ma pour julie qui malade mais non pas du
tout alors pourquoi faire venir le dr
barbiche sûrs et vient juste pour
prendre un verre de limonade dans la
nuit ne compte pas sur ma présence un la
dernière fois qu'il est venu il m'a
interdit de manger des goûts bulgarie
vient juste pour bavarder on ne sait
jamais écoute très bien monsieur du stop
parce qu'il ne le connaît pas monsieur
douce nomme lui aussi là horreur du
docteur je ne sais pas ce que vous avez
contre les docteurs c'est un très beau
métier ils sont là pour nous empêcher
d'avoir mal allez je compte sur vous
deux bon ben j'y vais
monsieur du snob monsieur dsna bon
secours vite réveillé la colère
de barbie qui va arriver il faut vite
aller se cacher la dernière fois qu'il
est venu il m'a interdit de manger du
tout brouillard pendant une journée la
gazinière je suis comme toi quand je
dois le docteur mallet les cheveux se
hérissent les yeux clean les dents
claque j'ai la gorge serrée une place
reste hommage le coeur par 6 jeux les
jeux ne risque pas de quoi j'ai peur
quoi auj voilà ce que nous allons faire
nous allons tout de même aller à
l'application julie
nous allons d'abord
[Musique]
où
louis
[Musique]
bonjour les dauphins
le club
va te voilà françois rineau afro choix
bonjour d'abord barbe issus eux vont
jouer le jeu jj au rouge est une ligne
comme tout en europe à crête ma robe à
paillettes mais j'ai un pantalon docteur
je le sais rien c'est julien geay vivait
très bien et qu'elle
gelli vous avez grandi au milieu de la
mer fournira je crois que c'est vous qui
vous êtes un peu tassé docteur clown ni
gauche 11 que je vous dis connu tenez
grant achatz mais j'ai tenu dans mes
bras moulin cours ses ventes en retz
c'est un vent tenez c'est fou comme le
temps passe vite pittman vous êtes julie
gilbert de limonade il sera le bienvenu
parce que
casimir messieurs du snob ils vont tenir
enfin moi je l'espère car dix mois à
casimir mais ce docteur m'a l'air tout à
fait innocent on peut peut-être mais il
vaut quand même mieux comme prévu puis
chiper sa sacoche son appareil à écouter
la respiration sa pelouse des toscans
déposez vos arrières la docteure oui
très bien comme ça je me sentirai un
petit peu ouverts
profitons-en je lui chipe ça voilà
quelques cachets vite ça derrière
l'arbre et
il recommence
oui mais voyons là je suis sûr que je
suis pas malade du tout docteur faut
partir oublie comme ça par tremblay au
moins deux vinyles à suivre évidemment
mais en fut et je vous fais peur oui
vous la fait un peu perdre comme un
vieux bonhomme comme moi mais enfin je
suis comme tout le monde mais je vais me
conseiller un champ
situé au numéro un c'est parce que j'ai
horreur d'être malade alors j'ai pensé
que les jo tu n'aimais pas chaque
journée
soulagé nous guérissent et c'est un très
joli meetic vous faites la docteure en
julien raison de tort je n'aurai plus
jamais par des docteurs levano plus
bon ben j'ai pas que je m'ennuie mais le
temps passe ne tend pas chez la route
est longue et n'ayant plus les gens de
20 emplois pédaler sur meuble secret je
m'essouffle leurs aptitudes ou ailleurs
vous avez dit vous vous est soufflé
attendez je vais vous à sculpter docteur
oui oui oui je crois que vous en avez un
peu besoin respirer très fort tous les
soirs est de 33,3 e313 à tirer la langue
une autre histoire or non écoutez là
j'allais vous faire une mauvaise passe
finalement vous mettre tellement
sympathique annick au lieu de vous
mettre à la vienne jean jaurès vous
inviter à dîner animé par
rené chez moi j'ai préparé un énorme
bluebeam car si
les bulls au nom non pas sa
maîtresse 15 mois
[Musique]